và lúc 2 2 2 1
nè hay mốt 3 năm năm nay những con trăm mẹ sấu
có mạnh thành phố chỉ mình tiếp nhận tìm báo của bịch sích nhật
đòa hay như hạm mở nước ngoại sử dụng mốt khi quần dụng về gián
sể ra tại trước nhà hàng hại sạm xế, nhựa chỉ mởi mở chương nghiệp của mến thành phố của chỉ mình
tại chỗ vi nhận nạn nhân tên Lê Mà Rô Rô Ngô Tò Bia, khúc thịt ốc
bị bánh 2 phát đạn từ từ vòng tại chỗ, và lạnh nhân sau lý 3 khúc thịt ốc
bị bánh 1 phát đạn bị từ nạn, khi hạm được chỉ tiếp tục tại việc
hạm sạm khi tiếp nhận tình báo, lòng chỉ chúng tưởng mai hàng tạm nó có mặt tổ, đã chỉ đạo
hò kỳng sắc những dự, và các lần bị nghiệp của cơm ăn phổ mễ thài
khởi trường phông gọi hệ trường, cấp gũ ngử dụng hình hại, lông thời
chú tập nối tổ nắng tại những dụng, có hợp với các dần bị nghiệp của cơm ăn
tổ chú lực lượng phục kiện áp dụng là bộ các vị thách nghiệp của
kết hợp lúc dụng bạng tổ, tại chỗ tựng tâm không tin trị vì có mặt tổ, lệp chí tốt 2 phù tổ
dẫn ch besond miếng bù kiến nấu cảo gibage tâm bác vứt np. đứng tộc, t microwave tục
tụi trên thị hại nếc vẻ để nhạc công hình gần.
Lực lượng không bao nhiêu tổ chình miếng đạo lần trên thông ek, tuyên sống mắt
chủ trái v În trР, có còn kẹt chắc khi trong còn kẹt kích với mình, đà bảo chủ
tùi ý ăn phón.
Cơm đại bóng người thách.
Cơm koi phần trị sát nhìn chặt, quốc độ hai đứng t 1400, cho n Vij phác đôi cây
an thương sự trị đạo của một tụi tụi tổ ổ đứt quanh.
Theo đó, nè, bình bụt 5 năm nay như tuần trà hà sấu,
hãy tự nực kệm và thành phố Chí Minh,
qua sân bài có thể ở sân nhất,
để hành miến cứu cưới lật hạt động của hà lệm nền.
Đi tối này, hay mất 5 năm nay như tuần trà hà sấu,
thì ra tây xác hại hà lệm nền hối bà phát tủ,
thì các lệm nền và nhóm bà,
hồi kết thúc mở tìm tại hà hà xie,
tất cứu tệ lựu trứng cứu tuần đường.
Cơ quan tình rất nhiều trà,
con mà phải tửa đá,
ra lệm nền hối trong trình hật tất,
lưới bối 2 đối tụt mở xam hoàn,
ra vơ bà và 3 RC và để tích thục tiêu tra về tổ thiết nguyệt.
Thông thời ra lệm nền hối trong trường hật tất đề năng hóa,
sự biến nền nữ tự nữ trọng giữa hà lệm tình tuổi,
khổ khổ thương trúng ốc năng,
tất cứ tình tại mình,
hay lưu đi phụt bất chuyện hà khóc thữ,
thành ổ như mình tình tại mình,
vạc bầy đối tụt mùi tình năng,
hỏi nền gwan,
vì đã không tử tất cả thác,
lưu thức trọng và chình đần trống của 2 thức thác.
Thông thạng là,
nó cảm ơn,
nóng đợi công an,
nó chỉ đợi,
quyết địa,
cũng mới sự chia sẻ,
cũng hộ,
đồng viên của các quyền chính quyền lịch phương,
đặc biệt,
nó tôi nghĩ đã rất cao vai trọng của chúng nhanh dịch.
Nó đồng hành của các nghiệm trong tiêm quan trọng,
đồng trợng,
thong ra phá ám để ta đất kích quả,
cao ngay hôm nay.
Để nghĩ tôi đến với kết tục,
nhớ chá màu dọc,
sĩ linh nghiệm,
các thình vì phát pháp lợp,
màu vẻ thức phục sống,
mình yên bản phúc,
của nền dần hình phố,
xin chất chọn cảm ơn,
tất cả tuyệt quan,
báo đàn,
đảo luôn chia sẻ,
đồng tình và uống phố,
chúng tôi trong,
tông tác,
là màu nền dịch thức,
nó chỉ là gì em,
và đặc biệt,
là,
chúng ta,
giữ gì,
chất tự ăn toàn xo hộ,
màu vẻ phục sống,
phy yên,
đặc phúc nền dịch,